you've tweeted that quote origin of life
research is a scam
so if this is shakespeare can we analyze
this word why why is the origin of life
research a scam aren't you kind of doing
origin of life research
um
okay it was tongue-in-cheek but yeah i
think and i meant it as tongue-in-cheek
um i am i'm not doing or i'm not doing
the origin of life research i'm trying
to make artificial life
and i also want to to bound the
likelihood of mate of the origin of life
on earth but more importantly to find
origin of life elsewhere but let me
directly address the tweet there are
many many good chemists out there doing
origin of life research but i want to
nudge them and i think they're brilliant
like like there's no there's there's no
question
the chemistry they are doing their
motivation is great
so what i meant by that tweet is saying
that maybe they're making assumptions
about saying if only
uh i could make this particular type of
molecule say this rna molecule or this
uh phosphodiester or this other molecule
it's going to somehow unlock the origin
of life
and i think that origin of life has been
looking at this for a very long time and
whilst i i think it's brilliant to
work out how you can get to those
molecules i think that chemistry and
chemists doing origin of life could
be nudged into doing something even more
profound and and so the argument i'm
making it's a bit like right now
let's say i don't know the first tesla
that makes its way to
i don't know into a new country in the
world let's say i let's say there's
country x that has never had a tesla
before and they get the tesla russia
and they take the test and what they do
is they take the tester apart and say we
want to find the origin of of cars in
the universe and say okay how did this
form and how did this fall
and they just randomly keep making until
they make the door they make the wheel
they make the steering column and all
this stuff and
and they say oh that's the route that's
the way that's the way cars emerge on
earth but actually we know that there's
a causal chain of cars going right back
to henry ford and the horse and carriage
and before that maybe you know um
where people were using wheels and and i
think that
obsession with the identities that we
see in biology right now are giving us a
false sense of
security about what we're looking for
and i think the origin of life chemistry
is in danger
of
of not making the progress that it
deserves because the chemists are doing
this as
the field is exploding right now there's
amazing people out there young and old
doing this and there's deservedly so
more money going in you know i used to
complain there's more money being spent
searching for the higgs boson that we
know exists and the origin of life
you know why is that the origin we
understand the origin of life we're
going to actually work out what life is
and we're going to be abound the
likelihood of finding life elsewhere in
the universe and most important for us
we are going to know
or have a good idea what the future of
humanity looks like you know we need to
understand that although we're precious
we're not the only life forms in the
universe or that's my very strong
impression i have no data for that it's
just right now a belief
and i want to turn that belief into a
more than a belief by by experimentation
but i coming back to the scam the scam
is if we just make this rna we've we've
got this you know this uh
this fluke event we know how that's
simple
let's make this phosphodiester or this
make atp or adp we've got that part
nailed let's now make this other
molecule another molecule and how many
molecules are going to be enough
and then
the reason i say this is when you go
back to craig venter
when
he invented
his life forms india
um this pla micro this this minimal
plasmid
oh it's a is a myoplasma something i
don't know the name of it but he made
this wonderful um cell and said i've
i've invented life
not quite he facsimiled the genome from
this entity and made it in the lab all
the dna but he didn't make the cell he
had to take an existing cell
that has a causal chain going all the
way back to luca and he showed when he
took out the gene the genes and put in
his genes synthesized the cell could
boot up but it's remarkable that he
could not make herself from scratch and
even now today synthetic biologists
cannot make a cell from scratch
because there's some contingent
information embodied outside the genome
in the cell
and that is just incredible
so there's lots of layers to the scam
you